want to go to pete ricketts right now
the nebraska governor
the co-chair of the republican governors
association and governor i'll get back
to you on that same subject here this is
a great interest to you
but what's interesting is it only seems
of great interest to some others in
these affected cities who are only now
worried about the plight of migrants
that they ignored when they were just in
texas or just on the arizona border then
it was you know a non-issue and then no
one said a peep about it now it's at
their doorstep and they're doing more
than peeping about it some are even
filing claims with the justice
department to protest what's being done
what do you think of this
yeah your previous guest was exactly
right and you're right this is
hypocritical behavior and again it's
just how this issue on the southern
border is impacting all of us that so
many of these officials wanted to ignore
i got to tell you here in nebraska one
of the things we've seen since the
divine administration has abdicated its
responsibility to defend our southern
border is a huge amount of
fentanyl and other illegal drugs coming
across the border coming to our state
and impacting our citizens we had a
young woman a mom of two tearling
griffith who took a counterfeit pill
with uh that was laced with fentanyl and
she died of an overdose and
unfortunately that's all too common
experience now where we see so much
fentanyl coming across the border and
it's killing our young people here in
states like nebraska
i'm just wondering as well governor then
where this goes if they're now i know
california governor newsom really wants
to take this case and have the
government look into how
you know these other governors
specifically you know governor desantis
in florida with this martha's vendor
thing and of course what's been
happening in texas with these buses
going to a lot of these sanctuary cities
but did not say boo about the many many
times
that president biden through ice has
done the same uh in much much greater
numbers uh with planes that left little
notice middle of the night you know the
drill better than anybody uh for all i
know nebraska got some of those so so
where is the the consistency here and
where is anything approaching solving
the problem here
yeah in fact there's no consistency in
fact you may recall that when the blind
administration was flying these uh
illegal immigrants around the country
they were landing as you point out in
the middle of the night and then denied
that they were even doing it uh you know
of course that raises concerns from my
colleagues like kim reynolds or bill lee
that this was actually human trafficking
and it was only under arrest it seemed
like that the federal government
actually admitted they were doing this
so they were they were trying to cover
this all up and of course uh my
colleagues in uh florida and in texas
have been doing this out in the open so
i think that again there's just
hypocrisy coming from the federal
government the buying administration
specifically about how this is being
handled and again i think you heard from
your previous guest this has been a huge
burden on our border towns that the
federal government hasn't done and and
of course the the by administration is a
hundred percent wrong when they say
they're doing more than the trump
administration we got to remember that
the policies the trump administration
put in place brought illegal crossings
to a 40-year low a 40-year low and here
you can't even get the press secretary
to say hey people don't come here
illegally don't break our laws and in
fact it's dangerous to do so we can't
even get them to say that well it's even
worse than that governor because the
reading is that there's no reading no
problem the border is secure
right that that does not advance go uh
governor thank you very much for taking
the time i went on brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now